can you comment on
uh tyson mike tyson oh yeah that thing
so first so he uh there's two things i
wanna so he's a in terms of fear
there's a clip there i think from a
documentary where he talks about he is
like fully afraid as he walks up to the
ring and as he gets closer and closer
and close he gets more confident
until he gets in and then he's a god or
something like that
that coupled with his statement on joe
rogan that he gets aroused
uh at the possibility of true like of
hurting somebody in the ring
so like he gets aroused at the violence
yeah uh
i like it because it's coupled to your
basically statement that we need to own
to find our own unique way of
existing at our top level of performance
and that perhaps is mike tyson but do
you think there's something more
deeply universal to the the mike tyson
speaking to the fact that he's aroused
that the possibility of yeah i do
actually uh although i don't think that
it always equates to arousal
for people in fact i would say in
general it doesn't yes uh
i can say i've never had a boner in the
ring in fact of anything you know old
combat [ __ ] is like
we're not hanging around we're leaving
we're going up yeah we're taking off
yeah we don't want anything to do with
this yes you have fun come back to us
when you have something
warmer softer smells better yeah but uh
the power the feeling of aliveness
yeah i could see it it being you know
back to the even the concept of the
ubermensch i feel like
the states the highest states of being
i've ever been in were in
the midst of conflict i felt like that
was the times those are the
those are the moments in my life where i
felt like i was at the highest level of
being
as a human in existence but yet
even being in that state was not it was
not
something that you could interact with
people that weren't in that state with
you like they wouldn't get it you would
almost seem and to be that way all the
time
either a might drive you mad or b is
you're not you're something that's
untenable to the rest of society like
you can't
function with everybody else it will not
work it's just like you said with the
uberman's just like it's
perhaps that ideal is not something you
can hold for long that's
the very nature of it yeah well there
was an example in the spoke
zarathustra about a snake being down
the person's throat and biting it
and then having this maniacal laughter
erupting and you know to me it was
at least i read it as yeah okay there's
this insane
moment that isn't forever but that it is
life and death
and it is and and the overcoming it is
the thing that all of a sudden gives you
that tapping
into the your your highest state right
this is you know
man is uh a chasm a tightrope between
uh man and ubermensch
you